hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i am your host evan carmichael
today's show is all about helping you as
an entrepreneur realize your dreams now
i know a lot of you may be struggling
you may feel like you're all alone in
this like nobody understands what you're
going through you may feel like
i thought it'd be further along you know
i'm putting in the work i'm putting in
the effort and i'm just not
getting
the momentum that i'm looking for i'm
just not hitting my goals i thought i'd
be further along than i am right now
that's what this show is all about okay
i was that guy i was the entrepreneur
making 300 bucks a month barely able to
survive and i turned my business around
and i got acquired and i've raised money
for entrepreneurs and i've built up
companies and this show was all about
helping you do the same thing and
achieve your goals on the agenda today
i'm talking about momentum how do you
find it how do you get it with your
business and how do you keep it going
the tool of the week the new feature
i've launched so i'm talking about my
newsletter software
uh mentorship how do you find mentors
and why are they important for your
business and then famous failures stores
of famous entrepreneurs there's a new
section that i'm watching in the show
stories of how they failed how they
failed early and what you can learn from
their success all right let's kick it
off momentum okay it's so important to
have momentum in your business now i
want to tell you a story my my condo now
it's a total mess a total mess there are
there are clothes all over the living
room floor my fridge is almost empty
today was the first time i shaved in a
week
and you might be thinking evan man what
the heck are you doing are you crazy
what's going on
i'm doing something big i'm doing
something that that i'm excited about
something that has given me massive
momentum
now i'm not making things public yet
this is this is just teaser for now but
there's a teachable lesson here for you
when you have momentum you want to stay
in it as long as possible
okay running the business it's hard
most of the time
you're just trying to keep up and stay
afloat
that's why momentum is important
momentum is where all the magic happens
when you've got momentum you're getting
things done quickly
things that might have taken you weeks
to do before are now flying off your
checklist you feel the energy that it
brings you you feel like your business
idea will work will actually work even
though everyone's telling you it won't
if you stop now
you're to kill your momentum
and this is where so many entrepreneurs
this is where they make a mistake
because you get a great idea you have
something that really really excites you
and you tell yourself
now you'll do it tomorrow or next week
right
and then you never do it right it just
sits there on your list of to do's
if you're excited about something if
you're feeling passionate about
something in the moment take action
right away
immediately
send an email out to somebody make a
phone call visit a store visit a library
go do some research something
and do as much as you can while you're
in the zone because that work
is going to be gold for you
the work you do in one week when you're
feeling the momentum will be worth more
than months of your usual work
push everything else your meetings your
calls your emails and so on your usual
daily routine it can wait
this is too important
pay attention to it
and don't let your momentum slip away
now i know what you're thinking you know
evan hey this kind of lifestyle is not
sustainable
and you know what you're right
you know i'm a neat freak
i hate having clothes on the floor it's
got to be tidy
you know i've got to eat
i need to have some food in the fridge i
need to eat and at some point i'm gonna
need to get a great night's sleep again
this is not a sustainable lifestyle it's
not sustainable for me it's not
sustainable for you
but here's the important thing to
remember when you're in the zone
being in that zone that's not
sustainable either
i don't know anyone who wakes up every
single day
and they're in their zone
you know if you're passionate about your
business you're passionate what you're
doing you really believe in it you're
not doing it just to make money you're
doing it because you have to do this
this is coming out of your heart
then that's a fantastic start
right if you're doing just to make money
forget about it
starting the business from your passion
that's how you start but you still don't
wake up every day in the zone so you
want to stay in that zone keep your
momentum as long as you can and when you
fall out of it go back to regular
routine
there's a huge difference between being
a workaholic and this is this is not
what i'm saying okay i don't want you to
be the workaholic i don't want you to
wear down your health i don't want you
to drive your friends away drive your
family away alienate your kids i don't
want you to do any of that stuff okay
that's not what i'm preaching here
there's a huge difference between being
that workaholic pushing everybody away
and maximizing the time you spend when
you're in the zone and you have momentum
all the best progress that i've made in
my businesses have come from
being in the zone
and using the momentum that i had
it's totally worth it
and so i want to encourage you to do the
same thing too
now a lot of people write into me
and
they don't know what their passion is
they don't know how to get in the zone
how to get into the momentum
and if you don't know what your passion
is yet if you haven't figured out how to
get into the flow yet the best thing
that you can do
is start to explore
explore and don't put so much pressure
on yourself to finding the next idea so
quickly
i want to tell you a quick story so
there are a couple things that i've
tried in the past few years
one was
rock climbing one was snowboarding and
one was salsa denton
and
with rock climbing i tried it and and i
didn't like it you know the the harness
was hurting me it was kind of wedging up
giving me a wedgie you know i don't like
heights i wasn't enjoying the rock
climbing experience with snowboarding i
learned it i loved it i got obsessed
with it every day i had to go
snowboarding it was what i really wanted
to do i became obsessed with it and then
with salsa dancing
i've learned it it's been 10 years i
still do it but with snowboarding after
my second year i started to lose
interest a little bit
and that's going to happen you're going
to have some ideas for your business
some ideas that you
you don't like you know like
you should not go into the rock climbing
business just because
you think it's going to make a lot of
money that's what a lot of entrepreneurs
do right to see an opportunity
like rock climbing they can make a ton
of money there the problem is you don't
love it
if you don't love it you're never going
to get momentum you're never going to be
in the zone you're never going to have
great moments because you don't love
that business
and that's a secret you have to love it
you have to love it to get in the zone
if you're starting a business around
snowboarding right that was my second
passion you may find that you love it
for a while
and then your interest fades
and that's okay
that's the time when maybe you have to
go and do something else
you know the the dirty little secret of
entrepreneurship is we all think about
quitting
everybody has thought about quitting you
never share that right you don't go to
networking events and people ask hey how
are you oh my god you know my business
sucks i wanna i'm thinking about giving
up this is too hard right nobody talks
about that but we all feel it everybody
has that thought at some point
in their company
and so when you're thinking about do i
keep going do i keep going or do i quit
what it should come down to is do you
love what you're doing or not
can you get in the zone again can you
feel that momentum again
because if you can't and if you're doing
it just for the money
you should have quit when you first
started
that was the time to quit so yeah quit
now but if you love what you're doing
it's important work to you you're
helping people
then you have to keep going and i know
it's hard running the business is hard
you have to be kind of crazy to be an
entrepreneur right when people are
telling you that it's not going to work
when you don't see any momentum when
there's no light at the end of the
tunnel and you're still sitting there
struggling
why do you keep going because you're a
little bit crazy and because it makes
you feel good and it should be something
that you would do even if you weren't
getting paid you look at the most
successful famous entrepreneur they
would do what they were doing look at
why they started it because they loved
what they did they would take on jobs
to do what they did just to pay the
bills because they loved it so much
that's what you need to find with your
company
that will help you get in the zone help
you find the momentum and when you get
in that zone
you have to stay there
as long as possible this show is all
about making you a success with your
business and today my tool of the week
is going to be having a newsletter and
my newsletter software is called aweber
now if you guys don't have a newsletter
you got to get a newsletter it's one of
my favorite ways to market
because people come to your website and
they may not buy from you right away and
a newsletter is an opportunity to build
a relationship with those prospects send
them awesome information
help them rise up
and then they'll be converted into
customers right when you need them to do
something you have a list of people to
market to
so my favorite software right now is
called aweber it's where all of my
newsletter subscribers are on and why i
love aweber is one of my favorite things
is
whenever you create an email
it
will score it for spam so one of the
biggest challenges of the email is you
know you have this big list of customers
and prospects and you send an email of
you don't want to be caught in their
spam filter right and so with aweber
it'll score each message that you send
out and it'll tell you hey by using
these words
whatever message you have you know these
four words in that email you send out
that's gonna get that's gonna cause it
to get in people's spam filters
and they'll tell you get rid of those
words and you'll score better and it's
such a useful tool that i found it has
all the other basic things that
newsletter software has you can schedule
messages out you can have pop-ups and
all the reminders and all that stuff but
that was my favorite feature so i would
encourage you guys go check out aweber i
don't have
any kind of relationship with them apart
from being a happy customer and i love
recommending tools entrepreneurs that i
think could help out so start building
your email list lab it doesn't matter if
you are in internet marketing or not any
business can benefit from having a
newsletter so i encourage you to go
check it out i want to get to the calls
rasheed are you still there yes right
shout out
oh richard sorry raise shadow all right
i gotta tell my producers to you know
spell that out for me my apologies what
uh what's your business and where are
you from
i'm from dayton ohio um i have a days
fine day in ohio um we've been open
since 2006 and i'm trying to expand and
venture off in some different avenues
but still in the hair industry
okay so what what is the business that
we do um i have a baseball i'm a salon
owner and operator
okay
and so
what's your challenge right now you need
you want to expand to new markets and
open new locations
well i'm actually i'm going to be in
texas
in july
to go to a hair replacement training
course
and that's what i'm wanting to do is
expand to be able to do the hair
replacement but also incorporate still
doing what we do here which is
we do hair nails massages facials
and makeup but i still want to
incorporate it all together i guess my
biggest issue is everything that i have
had at the salon i've actually bought
myself and worked to get but with me
wanting to do the hair replacement
business now i'm kind of needing to know
how do i go about possibly getting
investors to invest into
what i'm trying to do with the hair
replacement center because it can kind
of get a little pricey when it comes to
getting equipment and stuff how much
does it cost well the equipment ranges
anywhere to do to do the startup for the
business is about 25 grand total and
that's like to get like your different
pieces of equipment that you need
as far as with the laser because you'll
need a laser
um they have like a
oxygen treatment machine to open up the
scalp
to allow the hair to be able to grow
and they have a couple of other
different instruments that you need
it's not inventory it's machines that
you need to buy
yeah yeah and i by me having a day spa i
have a lot of things already
as far as equipment you know chairs
shampoo bows and things of that nature
so i would just really be expanding my
business
um
to add this on time have you been in
business since 2006
since 2006 yes okay perfect and
and you think your current customers
would this is a good add-on for them
right they're already coming into
something that they need you're not
selling to new customers necessarily
it's like your current customers would
love this
yeah there there are over
30
million people that are experiencing
hair loss that's a really really really
big market
so if i can actually provide this
service to the customer i don't think
that i would have a problem with getting
them to come
but are your current customers now what
part of your day spa are they asking for
this would they want it
we do have people um that come in that
that do get the service they are seeing
results from it because we have a laser
right now but we're not actually at your
replacement clinic per se
um we actually we just offer a service
for
thinning hair we're not actually a
clinic
which is more like a specialty type of
thing
so
two two quick thoughts for you the first
you're raising capital right and it's a
struggle that every entrepreneur goes
through especially when you need to buy
expensive equipment
the first there are financers you can
look at even the banks
what the banks love is
equipment right so they want something
that they can take back so if they know
that it's you know 25 000
worth of machinery
that's a lot easier to finance than if
you if you were trying to buy inventory
if you were trying to buy wigs if you're
trying to buy scissors or something
right it's a lot easier for them to take
back
uh and you've been in business for more
than three years which is what the banks
want to see as well so your first option
is to go and talk to the banks have you
talked to anybody there yet
no i haven't i haven't been um i i've
like i said i didn't do any loans
everything that i have is completely
paid for so i do have like
you know the collateral as far as um
assets but no yeah well it's worth a
discussion just to see how much it would
cost and what the monthly payments would
be and all that because it's way cheaper
for your business to take on a loan
to give up a piece of your company if
you're looking at an angel investor
who's going to own
whatever percent of your business
it's a lot cheaper to go to so at least
get get that option go in and this is
the deal that they want to do businesses
have been around for more than three
years and
there's an asset that they can take back
if you can't make the payment that's
what they want
the other option you can do is try to do
some pre-sales so talk to your current
customers and say hey this is something
we're thinking about what do you think
and get some pre-orders for it
and if you get enough people to help you
like your customers could help finance
part of the deal
okay
that's awesome
if your customers are already asking for
this
and you know you know if you raise x
amount of dollars maybe you can raise
ten thousand dollars from your current
customers put together a campaign
they could be the first people to
experience this new treatment that
you're going to come back with from
taxes
but they have to pay in advance to
reserve their spot
that's a great way that a lot of
businesses
raise capital to launch their new
initiatives well thanks for calling in
rachetta i'm on every two weeks and i'm
looking forward to hearing your update
congratulations and good luck with with
growing this business up for those of
you who are looking at getting financing
we typically think banks is the first
option but again banks banks want to see
an established business you've been
around for a little bit over three years
and they want to see something that they
can claw back in case you can't make
your payments so richard is actually a
great candidate
uh because she's going for access and
she's been around but it's not always
the best fit depending on what your
business is all about i believe in
entrepreneurs and this show is all about
helping make you a success and part of
that is getting mentors now my first
business was a software company and when
i started up i was full of excitement
energy you know i couldn't wait to get
going the world was mine for the taking
but the excitement wore off pretty
quickly when i realized just how hard it
was to make money i'm not talking about
big money i'm just talking about any
money now every day i hustled i grinded
i gave what i thought was everything i
had to my business and what did i have
to show for it
300
a month
that's all i could take out that's all i
could afford
you know i was embarrassed i was humbled
i never
felt so badly about myself
i felt like i was a failure i felt like
i was letting everybody down around me
you know here i was supposed to be
living the entrepreneur's dream and i
couldn't even afford 20 bucks to go out
and have dinner or drink with my friends
and i was frustrated because the the
books the tv shows the movies
it makes it look so easy
and all i could think of was why is it
so hard you know almost every day i
wondered if i should keep going if i
should do the smart thing and go get a
job
and then i hit bottom i couldn't send
the face i saw in the mirror anymore i
hated how i felt about myself
and i knew i was better than this
you know i felt like i had no words
and something had to change and i made a
commitment that i was gonna find a way
to make this business work or go do
something else
because i couldn't keep going as is
and the light bulb went off inside my
head this was the big sea change for me
i realized i wasn't the first guy to try
to sell software before
i didn't have to figure everything out
myself
and so i started researching large
companies like microsoft and how they
got started and you know i didn't care
about how
bill gates makes an extra million
dollars now right it's not interesting
but how do you go from zero to one
zero to one how did that happen
and bill gates did it with microsoft
through partnerships he found companies
who were selling to his target audience
and he made partnerships with them
and i thought okay i'm gonna i'm gonna i
got nothing else to lose i'm gonna try
this on my business and see what happens
and within a couple weeks of deciding to
follow this strategy
i closed my first partnership deal with
a company in europe that was 13 and a
half thousand dollars
for me up front now you know that may
not seem like a lot of money to you but
to me that was
i felt like crying that was huge i'm
making 300 bucks a month 13 and a half k
you kidding me that's huge and even more
powerful was i kept using that strategy
to go out and get more partnerships and
more partnerships and close more deals
and it led to us being able to take our
company from something i thought i'd
have to shut down and had zero worth to
getting some of the largest companies in
the world as customers we had johnson
johnson and nasa's customers and in a
couple years built up the business to
the point where we got acquired we had
customers in 30 countries and we got
acquired by uh an american company and
it was all because i modeled success
right i used bill gates even though i
didn't know him i used him as a mentor
to help me build my business and i
realized i'm not the first guy to try to
do this
and so if you're struggling with your
business right now you're not sure you
know what to do you're
you feel like doing the same thing your
momentum may have stalled model success
you could find a mentor somebody who's
actually gone out and done it who you
can meet face to face or you can also
learn from people who've done it before
you who may be much bigger than you by
reading their stories and learning from
them apply their strategies make it work
for you it'll drastically shortcut your
path of success and i highly recommend
you check it out i have a longtime
listener loyal listener and caller maria
varela on the line mrs inspire how are
we doing maria i'm good evan how are you
welcome back thank you it's it's really
exciting to be on the show today um i
follow you constantly and actually
talking about mentors you're you're one
of the first persons that i go to when i
go on twitter
google plus everywhere and
i'm finding that
when you help me with my one word it
really took off
and when it took off i noticed that
people that were doing marketing and
promoting and stuff like that started
putting a lot of inspirational stuff in
between all of their
marketing or their whatever they were
selling
and i thought wow some something's
happening i'm seeing a shift i'm seeing
the shift everywhere
and then google plus kind of took off
with the views and um
i watch your youtubes constantly now i'm
kind of at a
standstill because i'm i'm not sure
where to go from here
i've connected with a lot of people that
are positive inspirational they've
written books um things of that nature
but i don't know someone had told me
about branding
um and i'm not really sure like where do
i go from here because i like i'm seeing
the shift i'm actually seeing it all
over the place everywhere
and people that never would write or
post are now posting
and
i mean which is a great thing so my my
my hashtag to inspire to inspire the
world is working
so how do i make it work
better for myself
so this is great so the last time you
called in you were kind of all over the
place there was no direction but you had
a lot of energy
having that one word help focus you
which is great and i've seen some of
your stuff and it's great and and now
you have clarity
and people can understand a little bit
more about what you're doing and you
have you have momentum and you have
people who would be willing to help you
who are like-minded people so you have
this momentum building which is great
now what you need to do is focus
on a project
so
where do you want all the energy to go
where do you want all these people to
help you out i remember before you were
talking about i don't know the book or
dance choreography and a whole bunch of
different projects
so find what's the project that you can
now
push everybody towards and say hey
here's what i'm doing that relates to
inspire and i need your help to help me
launch this thing
what's that project well i've been
approached by several um acting coaches
to
um take some acting classes which is
something that i did way in the past but
also public speaking
so
i love to write writing is what i love
to do
and that's where all these authors and
they're all positive they're all
you know very um a lot of energy and
that's where that's my inner circle and
someone had told me the the time that
you spend with the what is it
the five people that you spend the most
time with is what your circle becomes
and so what i've done is i've eliminated
a lot of people
that didn't have the same like goals or
or
things of that nature but not too much
because they could also be looking for
that inspiration
so i'm not i i don't really know where
to go from here i don't know if i should
just start doing youtubes and then see
where that takes it and then continue on
with the book
okay so if you're not understand you
don't know where to drive all this
energy then the best thing you can do is
explore
and know that that the right project is
going to come up and it'll come up from
you trying different things until you
find something that you love
if you try to force something right now
i know it's hard like you're you're
struggling i i i gotta make something
happen here i have all this potential
nothing's happening yet i don't know
where to focus everything but if you try
to rush it too early then you're going
to pick the wrong thing
and so you have to keep experimenting
and keep trying a whole bunch of
different things until you find
something that you fall in love with
a quick example from my story is a salsa
dancing when i first went into salsa
dancing i wanted to try it out
uh
not for a business idea just to explore
and try it out and see if i had fun
because everything on paper looked
looked bad you know like i i i didn't
know the dance i didn't grow up with
that i didn't speak spanish i was too
tall it's like huge steps i didn't have
the rhythm
so on paper it looked like a terrible
idea but i went and i fell in love and
it became something that i had to keep
learning and it became a business
opportunity and i invested in a company
and i helped teach and i dj and it's
become a huge part of my life
and so you want to keep testing out
small tasks little experiments and know
that something will come
and when you find that project
you'll know in your heart that it's the
right thing to do and that's where you
dive in and then pool all of these
people and all those moments like here
this is what i want to explode let's go
do
this okay
so try that
try the youtube thing right
you may do one acting lesson and think
wow this is this is not gonna want to do
this and and then you know or you may go
and say wow this is amazing i want to
keep going
right right thank you
experiment try and don't be afraid to
keep trying things until you find the
one that you fall in love with and want
to run with okay fantastic
good luck
and tell me how it's going
i sure will thank you so much
thanks maria
and for all of you listening if you
haven't found that passion yet i know
it's strong it's it's frustrating you're
struggling you want something now
entrepreneurs we want something now
right we want it to happen right now but
the best thing you can do is explore
small starts small failures see what
hits and as with all matters of the
heart you'll know when you find it
hello and welcome back to evan
carmichael show i believe in
entrepreneurs and
one thing that i want you guys to really
take home and remember is that you will
have a lot of failure on the path of
success
it's gonna happen for every famous
entrepreneur who's had lots of success
if you look at their story it wasn't
just i had an idea and boom overnight
became this big success they had lots of
failure along the way and so i thought
i'd launch a new segment on the show
today called famous failures and i'm
hoping to continue it as you go along
with the series
basically looking at a different person
and see how they failed early on and how
you can learn from that success so today
i want to talk about marilyn monroe
now marilyn monroe
obviously one of the most you know
celebrated actresses ever in the in the
world and when she had her first
contract when she was super young
in 1947 she had her first acting
contract she's with 20th century fox
they gave her one year contract and the
production chief daryl zenik at the time
refused to
continue on with the deal and actually
let her go
because he said that she was
unattractive
marilyn monroe
one of the sexiest women on the planet
ever
was told
that she was unattractive
and was fired from her contract
think about that
one of my
one of my things is you know these guys
i call them the little man okay so daryl
zanik this production chief he's the
little man you're gonna have the little
man in your life the people who don't
believe in you the people who
tell you you're unattractive
when you're not and tell your ideas
stupid when it's not who just can't see
the vision that you see
and you're gonna you're gonna come
across these people
a lot in your life
and sometimes
they're your friends sometimes they're
your family
and you know what i find it often it's
easier to get criticism from your
friends and family because you can you
can always say you know what they don't
know what they're talking about
they don't know what they're talking
about
you know they have no experience
but sometimes the little man knows what
he's talking about
right he's an expert
he's had years of experience
daryl zanik production chief at 20th
century fox
has had years of experience
and this is the guy telling marilyn
monroe that she's unattractive and
letting her go from her contract
so sometimes the expert they don't know
what they're saying
right they're they're basing their views
on the world that exists in their head
that may not be your reality
and so what do you do
this decision time
when the people around you tell you that
you're not going to make it the experts
in the field say you know it's a stupid
idea you're unattractive forget about it
quit leave give up
what do you do
that's when it really tests you
that's when it really tests you as to is
this the right thing for you or not
because it's not going to be an easy
pass
you're going to have to fight for it
do you really love it enough to keep
going
what if marilyn monroe had listened to
this guy and and thought to herself you
know what i'm not i'm not attractive i
can't make it as an actress
what would have happened to her life
would have been totally different than
what she got
and the same thing can happen to you if
you listen to that criticism
if you stop
because somebody tells you that it's not
a good idea but deep down in your heart
you feel like
you don't know what else to do this is
what you love
then you have to find a way to keep
going
and stop listening to the little men
i've got time for one last question i'm
going to take one from twitter we've got
a lot of questions coming in on the
twitter channel this one is from
steampressmedia
who is asking me who is my mentor who do
i look up to
my favorite entrepreneur of all time
is ap giannini
and he's the founder of bank of america
you might be saying ep janine who is
this guy and a banker what the heck man
a banker is your favorite entrepreneur
this guy is not your typical banker
okay he started off not in the banking
industry and he was asked to join the
board of directors for bank called
columbus loans and savings and he joined
as a board member and he saw that the
bank was only giving out
loans to wealthy people and he said you
know what there's all these immigrant
workers here there's all these small
business owners who
they work really hard and i think if we
give them some money they'll pay it back
and they'll be honest people
and they said knox that's crazy we can't
see that that's way too risky
so he got so upset with him that he left
the board and he opened up his own bank
right across the street
from columbus savings and loan
talk about ballsy and he started giving
out loans to hard-working people the
little man the little guys right like
the the
the hard-working immigrants and small
business owners who nobody wanted to to
give a shot to
he was the guy
and his business started to grow and it
became bank of america one of the
largest banks in the world
and one of my favorite stories
is when there was
a fire in san francisco
that totaled the whole city all the
buildings were were on fire burnt down
businesses needed money to get their
lives back in order they need to pay for
things and all the banks they shut down
because their buildings have been shut
down and what ap janine did was he went
to his bank which had been burned to the
ground he took out two barrels and he
took a plank of wood and he brought a
chair out
and he opened up shop because he knew
that these people needed money to
rebuild their lives and he didn't have
any records he has nothing people came
to him they formed a line and he made a
loan to people based on what he said a
look in their eye and a handshake deal
are you kidding me
what kind of banker imagine going to
your bank
looking them in the eye and shaking
their hand and then giving you a deal
right it doesn't happen
but that was what he believed in he
wanted to support the hard-working
entrepreneurs and give them a hand up
because sometimes we all need a little
bit of help and so that's why he's my
favorite entrepreneur he's somebody who
i've tried to model he's been my mentor
even though he died way before i was
even born
but i encourage you to look at those
stories like find somebody who you look
up to learn from them take lessons from
their success
and apply it to your business
it's been another great show thank you
guys so much for calling in uh thank you
lauren and josh for all the great work
producing the show again join me on
twitter i'm at evan carmichael and i
will see you in two weeks for the next
show